The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our main aim today
is to successfully
conclude block three,
and to set the stage
for introducing block four.
Now by way of brief review,
we may have become so involved
with our discussion of
the last few lessons
where we've done the chain
rule, that we may have forgotten
that the basic ingredient
that we had arrived at,
that set up our proof
of the chain rule--
and then after that,
we got involved
in the computation of how
to use the chain rule.
But the basic
ingredient was the idea
that we had obtained a linear
approximation, a delta w tan
idea.
And this concept leads to the
idea of a differential, which
is an extension of the
idea of differentials
as we knew them in
part one of our course.
And what I would like to do
is to talk somewhat briefly
about this topic, to show
how it introduces what
will be the main
body of material
in block four and an
important application
that we can handle now that
will show why it's worth
understanding certain things
about differentials, even
on a very elementary level.
At any rate, the topic
that I've chosen for today
is called "Exact Differentials."
And the idea,
again, is completely
analogous to what we did in
calculus of a single variable.
We start with w
equals f of x, y.
And we showed that if w was
a continuously differentiable
function of x and
y, it made sense
to emphasize the expression
called delta w tan, which
was the partial
of f with respect
to x evaluated at a
given point times delta
x, plus the partial
of f with respect
to y at that same
point times delta y.
And what we do is the
same thing that we did,
as I say, in calculus
of a single variable.
We introduce a new language.
We write delta w tan now as dw.
We write delta x as
dx, delta y as dy.
And what we say is that dw is
the total differential of w.
To see how this is analogous
to what happened in calculus
of a single variable, notice,
for the sake of argument,
that if f happens to be
a function of x alone,
so that there is
no second variable.
In other words, if f
is independent of y,
notice that the partial of f
with respect to y will be 0.
And we will then have that
w is a function of x alone.
dw, then, will be what?
Well in that case, the
partial of f with respect to x
is the ordinary derivative of
f with respect to x times dx.
And we're back to our old recipe
that dw is dw/dx times dx.
That this is a natural extension
of what happened in calculus
of a single variable.
All right?
Now what leads
into the next block
and why we're going to drop this
for the time being but to go up
to a different
aspect of this, is
notice that if we can
assume that dw can replace
delta w-- if we can
assume, as we talked
about in the case
of continuously
differentiable functions, that
the difference between delta w
and delta w tan is negligible
for sufficiently small delta
x and delta y, notice that the
equation dw equals f sub x dx
plus f sub y dy, since f sub
x and f sub y are computed
at a given point,
these become what?
Linear combinations of dx
and dy, a constant times dx
plus a constant times dy.
And we're into the subject
of linear equations, which
we will talk about next time.
For the time being,
all I want to point out
is that dw is called the
total differential of w.
And that conversely, starting
with any expression of the form
some function M of x and y
times dx plus some function
N of x and y times
dy-- in other words,
M of x, y dx plus N
of x, y dy, no matter
what functions of x
and y M and N are,
any expression of this form
is called a differential.
By the way, you
may recall that you
were used to calling dx a
differential back in calculus
of a single variable.
Notice that in particular,
one choice of capital N
is to have N of x,
y be identically 0.
We could have M of x,
y be identically 1.
In which case, M*dx plus N*dy
would simply be 1*dx plus 0*dy,
or dx.
In other words, notice that
this extended definition
of a differential for
two or more variables
includes the definition
for a single variable.
At any rate, any
expression of this type
is called a differential.
And again, a very natural
question that comes up
is who wants differentials?
Why do we need them?
And perhaps the best
application comes
from the clue that
a certain subject is
called "Differential
Equations," rather than
derivative equations.
Let me illustrate this
in terms of what I think
is a rather nice
example, in the sense
that it will be hard
to guess the answer,
but rather easy to visualize
what the problem says,
at least.
Let's imagine that I
have a certain curve
S in the xy-plane.
I don't tell you anything
else about that curve
except that its slope
at any point x comma y
is given by the very
interesting relationship
that it's the quotient of
the square of its distance
from the origin over twice the
product of its coordinates.
In other words, to find
the slope of the curve S
at the point x comma y, I
square the distance of the point
from the origin, take
the negative of that,
divide by twice the
product of the coordinates,
and that's going
to be the slope.
Now certainly that makes
sense geometrically.
But what type of a curve
would have that property?
And even assuming that we knew
such a curve, how in the world
can you express it in
a convenient manner?
Well here's the idea.
Again, back to
the same technique
that we used in calculus
of a single variable.
Algebraically, this
is our equation.
If we cross-multiply and
collect all our terms
onto one side of
the equation, we
obtain what we call the
differential equation, see?
It's an equation
involving a differential.
In fact, in this case, using
our general notation, M of x, y
is x squared plus y squared.
And N of x, y is 2x*y.
We have a differential
equal to 0.
Now without going
into this right now,
suppose I just happen to
have a very quick eye.
Well in fact, before I even say
that, let me point this out.
We've had problems like this
in part one of our course.
The main difference was
that we could separate out
the variables.
We could get the x's
and the y's separated.
Remember now, y is implicitly
a function of x here,
in this expression,
because of the equation.
See? x and y are no
longer independent
when we equate this to 0.
The question is though,
we cannot separate
the x's and the y's here.
But if we were lucky-- that's
where luck comes in-- we would
recognize that treating
y as a function of x,
the differential on
the left-hand side
is precisely the differential
of 1/3 x cubed plus x squared y.
In other words, the partial
of this with respect to x is
simply x squared-- do I have...
I think I may have
this thing in reverse.
Let me make sure.
If I take the partial of
this with respect to x,
I have 1/3 x cubed
plus 2x*y, right?
And if I take the partial
with respect to y,
I simply have x squared.
At any rate-- what
I'm saying is,
if we knew a function whose--
see, I have this in reverse.
That's what's bothering me here.
I think the square
should go this way.
That's not important.
All I'm saying is if I've
done this thing correctly,
if you take the partial
of this with respect
to y-- with respect x,
you should get this.
If you take the partial
of this with respect to y,
you should get this.
And that comes
out correctly now.
In other words, the partial
of this with respect to x
is x squared plus y squared.
The partial of this with respect
to y-- this term drops out,
and there's just 2x*y.
I'm sorry for that
little mistake.
But I won't really apologize
for it in the sense
that once we've found it--
or even if we didn't find it,
the key theory is the same.
The point is that if we knew a
function whose differential was
this, then the fact that
this differential is 0
means the expression
itself must be a constant.
In other words, 1/3 x cubed plus
x y squared must be a constant.
And therefore, what
we're saying is if we now
solve the equation-- I
really am sorry to have
botched this for you.
But again, as I say,
the idea basically
comes through unimpeded.
I now solve for y in terms
of x, and I get what?
That y is equal to--
transposing here--
plus or minus the square
root of c minus 1/3 x
cubed, all over x.
In other words, the
family of curves
that satisfies this
differential equation
is precisely this family here,
whatever that may look like.
In other words,
this is the family
of curves that has the
interesting slope property
that we just discussed.
Now you see, again,
the reason I say
that I wasn't too
concerned about what
this function actually
was is, notice
that I was just pulling it out
of the hat for you here anyway.
I said suppose we could
find a function w such
that dw was this.
The major question that comes
up in how one uses differentials
and the like is as follows.
Suppose all I told you was
that we had the differential x
squared plus y squared dx plus
2x*y*dy, and I said to you,
find a function w such that
dw will be x squared plus y
squared dx plus 2x*y*dy.
The key computational aid in
doing this involves the fact
that if u and v are
independent variables--
and it's crucial that
they be independent--
that if a*u plus b*v
equals c*u plus d*v,
it must be that a equals
c, and b equals d.
In other words, the only way
that two linear combinations
of independent
variables can be equal
is if they're equal
coefficient by coefficient.
You see, the proof
is very simple.
Namely, after all, if u and
v are independent variables,
why can't I pick v to be 0,
let u be any non-zero number.
Then if v is 0, when
I equate these two,
it says a*u equals c*u.
Since u is not 0, I can cancel,
and obtain that a equals c.
And in a similar way letting u
equal 0, I have b*v equals d*v.
I can cancel the v's
and get that b equals d.
But it's crucial that
u and v be independent.
Because if u and v
are not independent,
how do I know that I can have
u equal to 0 when v is not 0?
For example, let's suppose
that v and u were dependent.
Suppose, for example,
that v equals twice u.
Observe, in this case, that
9u plus 4v-- since v is 2u--
turns out to be 17u.
On the other hand, 7u plus 5v is
7u plus 10u, which is also 17u.
Notice that 9u plus
4v equals 7u plus 5v,
even though the coefficients
don't line up as far
as being equal is concerned.
You see?
In other words, notice that
being able to equate things
coefficient by coefficient
hinges on the fact
that the variables that we're
dealing with are independent.
And the key thing going
back to this problem
is, what were dx and dy?
They were delta x and delta y.
And as long as x and y
are independent variables,
certainly the change in x
can be done independently
of the change in y.
In other words, dx and dy
are independent variables.
So if we now say, let's find
that function w such that dw is
x squared plus y
squared dx plus 2x*y*dy,
the one thing we know
about dw, if it exists,
by our basic definition of
this section of this lecture,
is that dw is the partial of f
with respect to x times dx plus
the partial of f with
respect to y times dy.
Since dx and dy are
independent variables,
the only way these two
expressions can be identical
is coefficient by coefficient.
That means in
particular, therefore,
that the partial
of f with respect
to x, which is the
coefficient of dx here,
must be x squared
plus y squared, which
is the coefficient of dx here.
And similarly, the partial of
f with respect to y must equal
2x*y.
Now, armed with
this information,
I can actually go
out and construct f.
And the way I do
this is remember--
as soon as I see the partial
of f with respect to x,
it means I'm treating
y as a constant.
If I'm treating y as a constant,
I just integrate this thing
as if x were the only variable.
Treating x as a variable
and y as a constant,
the integral of x
squared is 1/3 x cubed.
The integral of y
squared is simply
y squared x, because y is
being treated as a constant.
And finally, there must be
a constant of integration,
but my constant now
is any function of y.
In other words, if
I have any function
of y, its partial with respect
to x, by definition of x and y
being independent-- the
partial of any function
of y with respect to x is 0.
Therefore my constant of
integration, in this case,
is a function of y alone.
Again, to look at this in a
different perspective, what
I'm saying is the
most general function
of two variables
in the whole world
whose derivative
with respect to x
is x squared plus y squared
is 1/3 x cubed plus y squared
x plus a function of y alone.
Now all I don't know so far
is what specific function of y
is g?
In other words, I've
determined f now up
to this particular arbitrary
constant of integration.
How do I get a
hold of this thing?
Notice that as yet, I have not
used a piece of information
that tells me the partial of
f with respect to y is 2x*y.
And to utilize that piece
of information, what I do
is I come to this equation,
and I say, lookit.
Let me, from here, just
differentiate this with respect
to y, treating x as a constant.
If I do that, this
term drops out.
This term becomes 2x*y.
And this, being a
function of y alone,
its derivative with respect
to y is just g prime of y.
So whatever f is, the derivative
of f with respect to y is 2x*y
plus g prime of y.
On the other hand, we also
know that the partial of f with
respect to y is 2x*y.
Consequently, since these
are two different expressions
for the same quantity,
they must be equal.
Equating these two,
the 2x*y's cancel.
We obtain that g prime of y is
0, which means, in this case,
that g of y was a bona
fide constant, that not
only is g independent of x,
it's also independent of y.
And we see that the
most general function
f which has the desired
property is what?
All we have to do is now go
back to this expression here,
which gave us the
answer up to g of y,
put this value of g of y in,
and we see that the most general
function whose total
differential is x squared plus
y squared dx plus 2x*y*dy is 1/3
x cubed plus y squared x plus
c.
And I guess there's a moral
to this story, after all.
You know?
When I did it the
quick way, I made
a careless computational
mistake earlier
in the lecture that sort
of threw me off a bit
and perplexed me.
And it seems it
was poetic justice.
Because, you know,
when I took this method
where we pretended we didn't
know the answer in advance
and just worked the
thing out systematically,
we came up with the right term.
In other words, it should be
y squared x, not y x squared.
And that was what we saw
should be the correct answer.
So maybe there's something
to be said about doing things
systematically, after all.
You see?
If I can't win
them all, at least
I have the gift of rationalizing
to think that I win them all.
Time after time, I snatch
defeat from the jaws of victory.
No?
All right.
You know what I mean.
Lookit.
Anyway, the question that
we've now solved is what?
We have worked out this routine.
Notice that what
we are really doing
is the counterpart of calculus
of a single variable, that
knowing what a partial is,
we can integrate with respect
to that variable, treating
all the other variables
as a constant.
And this is the
general technique.
Now let's summarize
this more generally.
The general definition is this.
And by the way, for the sake
of conserving space, I will now
abbreviate M of x, y and
N of x, y just by M and N.
But whenever I
write M and N here,
it's assumed that M and N
are functions of x and y.
Well what we say is this.
M*dx plus N*dy,
which by the way,
by a previous definition
is always a differential.
But this differential is
called an exact differential
if and only if there exists
a function w-- f of x, y--
such that dw is M*dx plus N*dy.
Or in terms of our
previous discussion,
what this means is what?
dw is also equal to f
sub x dx plus f sub y dy.
Since x and y are
independent variables,
dx and dy are
independent variables.
So an alternative
definition is what?
That M*dx plus N*dy is an exact
differential if there exists
a function f such that the
partial of f with respect to x
is M, and the partial of
f with respect to y is N.
Now, by the way, let's just
pause here for a moment.
You might suspect that
with all the functions
to choose from, that no
matter how M and N were given,
we're bound to find at least
one function which satisfies--
I should put this
in, because you
want both of these conditions
fulfilled at the same time.
The amazing thing is
that it is not always
possible to find
a function which
has a given differential
as its total differential.
In fact, let me show you why,
if we can just do something
a little bit tricky here.
Let's suppose that the
function f exists such
that its partial
with respect to x
is M and its partial
with respect to y
is N. Suppose that both of these
happen to be differentiable.
Take the partial of f
sub x with respect to y.
That tells me that f sub
x, y is the partial of M
with respect to y.
Let's take the partial of
f sub y with respect to x.
That tells me that the partial
of f sub y with respect
to x is N sub x.
In other words, f sub
y, x equals N sub x.
Now if f is
continuous-- see, if we
have the right
amount of continuity
and differentiability
that we've talked
about in previous
lectures, notice
that for most well-defined
functions-- in particular,
if these two partials-- see,
we don't know what f is.
We're trying to find f.
And we're assuming it exists.
The thing that's given
in our definition
are M and N. So to word this
more succinctly, if it turns
out that the partial
of M with respect to y
and the partial of
N with respect to x
happen to be
continuous functions,
notice that these
two things are equal.
And in particular, that
means that the partial of M
with respect to y has to
equal the partial of N
with respect to x.
Coming back to the
original definition here,
this is a rather amazing thing.
It says that if this
differential is exact,
if you take the
coefficient of dx--
see, think of M as being
the coefficient of dx and N
as being the coefficient of dy.
If you take the
coefficient of dx
and differentiate that
with respect to y,
you must get the
same answer as if you
took the coefficient of
dy and differentiated that
with respect to x.
That's an amazing
coincidence if that happens.
Given two arbitrary functions,
this indeed won't happen.
Now before I show you
that, let's summarize this
in words written down
so that I make sure
that you understand
what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is, if the
partial of M with respect to y
and the partial of N with
respect to x are continuous,
then if M*dx plus N*dy is
exact, the implication is that
the partial of M with respect
to y must equal the partial of N
with respect to x.
And to invert the emphasis here,
another way of saying this is
that if the partial of M with
respect to y is not equal
to the partial of N
with respect to x,
then M*dx plus
N*dy is not exact.
And let me show you that
by means of an example.
Let's look at the differential--
a very simple-looking one.
In fact, it looks far less
complicated than the expression
that we worked with previously.
Let's look simply
at y*dx minus x*dy.
In this problem, the
coefficient of dx is y.
That plays the role of M. The
coefficient of dy is minus x.
That's what we're
calling N, you see.
And the partial of
M with respect to y
is just the partial of y with
respect to y, which is 1.
The partial of N
with respect to x
is the partial of minus x with
respect to x, which is minus 1.
Since 1 is not equal to
minus 1, this is not exact.
Because if it were
exact, these two partials
would have to be equal.
What does it mean to say
that this is not exact?
What it means is
that there is not
a single function in
the whole world that
has the property that its
partial with respect to x is y,
and it's partial with
respect to y is minus x.
You can look forever.
And not only won't you
find one, there isn't one.
And by the way, let me make
one very quick aside here.
Notice the difference between
saying you can't find one,
and there isn't one.
There may be one,
and you're just not
lucky enough to find it.
I'm saying that the reason you
don't find an answer here--
unless you make a mistake and
think you've found an answer--
the reason you don't find
an answer is there is none.
And how can I show you
that there is none?
Well the best way is
to do the same thing
that we did in the
previous example,
and see something go wrong.
Let's suppose there
were an answer to this.
Well if the partial of f
with respect to x equals y,
let me integrate
this with respect
to x, treating y as a constant.
It means that the function
that I'm looking for
must have what form?
It's x times y plus some
function of y alone.
And now we say, gee, we're
in pretty good shape.
All we've got to do is find what
g of y is, and we're home free.
Let's continue to mimic
what we did before.
Knowing this, I can take the
partial of this with respect
to y, OK?
Which is what?
If I take the partial of
this with respect to y,
this is f sub y is
x plus g prime of y.
All right?
Now this is the partial
of f with respect
to y, computed from here.
I know by hypothesis that
the function I'm looking for
must have its partial with
respect to y equal to this.
Consequently, these two
expressions must be equal.
And equating these
two expressions says
that g prime of y--
see, x plus g prime of y
must equal minus x.
Transposing says that g
prime of y is minus 2x.
And this is a contradiction.
Because lookit, g prime of
y is a function of y alone.
And here we have it equal
to some function of x.
Or another way of
looking at it, this
says that x depends on y. x
is some function of y, which
is a contradiction since
we assumed that x and y are
independent variables.
By the way, just
as a quick aside,
notice that in the case where we
were able to succeed at this--
namely the previous example, x
squared plus y dx plus 2x*y*dy,
M was x squared plus
y squared, N was 2x*y.
Notice that the partial of
M with respect to y is 2y.
And the partial of N with
respect to x is also 2y.
So it seems that the
deciding factor really
seems to be that the partial
of M with respect to y
has to equal the partial
of N with respect to x.
And the major result is--
and I didn't write this in,
because I didn't want to
use up too much space.
But this is emphasized in the
text and in the exercises.
If M, N, M sub y, and N sub x
all exist and are continuous,
then not only can we say that
M*dx plus N*dy is exact implies
this part, but we can
do the converse too.
That in particular, if
M sub y equals N sub x,
we can conclude
that this is exact.
And the reason for
this-- and I'll
go through this very
quickly because the proof is
given in the text.
I just want to show you the
highlights of what happens is,
what really happened
when we tried
to construct f that made
things work in one case
but not in the other?
I think the best way to do
this is to work abstractly
here without specifying
what M and N are,
and see what happens.
What we were trying to solve
was a pair of equations--
we were trying to find f
such that the partial of f
with respect to x is M,
partial of f with respect to y
is N. The first
thing that we did
was we treated y as a
constant and integrated this
with respect to x.
Well, I can't do
this specifically,
because I don't know what M is.
So let me just put the integral
sign in here to say what?
I'm integrating
this with respect
to x, treating y as a constant.
That's some function of x
and y, you see over here.
See M is a function of x and y.
I'm holding y constant.
I'm integrating this.
Plus a constant of integration
which depends only on y.
All right?
Same as before.
What was my next step?
I took the partial of
this with respect to y,
and I was going to
compare that with what
I knew the partial of
f with respect to y
had to be-- namely, N.
So I then took what?
The partial of this
with respect to y.
That gave me the partial of
this integral with respect
to y plus g prime of y.
And equating that to N,
I get that g prime of y
was N minus the partial with
respect to y integral M dx.
And again, don't be
alarmed by this expression.
If M had been
given explicitly, I
would have solved explicitly
for what this function was.
The key point is to
notice that this side here
is independent of x.
Consequently, this equation
will be a contradiction
unless the right-hand
side is independent of x.
In other words, we
have determined f up
to this function g of y.
And what's going
to happen is we are
going to be able
to compute g of y
if this expression is
independent of x, namely just
by integrating this.
But if g of y is not independent
of x, we are in trouble.
It means that it's
not going to exist.
The key step is, is
this independent of x?
And the answer is, the
best way to find out
in terms of calculus is to take
its derivative with respect
to x.
If this depends on y alone,
its partial with respect to x
must be 0.
In other words, if this partial
with respect to x is not 0,
it means that this
expression varies with x.
At any rate, to see
what this derivative is,
we just differentiate
term by term.
And then we say, you know?
It's rather interesting.
If this thing had been first--
notice that if you integrate
with respect to x and
then differentiate
with respect to x, you wind
up with just the integrand.
Well again, if we have
enough continuity,
the order of differentiation
is irrelevant.
We can reverse the order
without changing anything
if we now interchange
this order,
take the partial first
with respect to x.
That will give us just
M. And the partial
of M with respect to y
is just the partial of M
with respect for y, of course.
What we're saying is that from
this step, we get to this step.
And this in turn implies this.
Notice that the only
way that this can be 0
is if the partial of
N with respect to x
equals the partial of
M with respect to y.
So in summary then, this is
a very interesting device.
It tells us how to tell whether
a differential is exact.
And the proof is very
nice in this case
because the proof
exactly imitates
how we construct the function
f if it turns out to be exact.
But the point is, if
given M*dx plus N*dy,
if the partial of M with
respect to y is not equal
to the partial of N
with respect to x,
there's no hope that the
function will be exact--
the differential be exact.
At any rate, we will
have sufficient exercises
for drill in how one
uses exact differentials.
This concludes block
three of our material.
Our next block of
material which will
concern linear
systems of equations
will begin with
our next lecture.
And until next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.